Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, hast du eigentlich schon mal Google gegoogelt?
Tim, wenn du Google bei Google eingibst, kannst du das Internet kaputt machen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 468 vom 7. September 2023.
Ja, und fast wäre das ganze Internet kaputt gegangen.
Ja, sorry, ich hab mir das doch schon wieder heimlich gemacht.
Das autorative Dokument. Ja, das ist wirklich jetzt den Witz,
kleiner Hinweis, den Witz haben wir uns nicht selber ausgedacht.
I don't think that's true. With all due respect, John, I am head of IT and I
have it on good authority.
If you type Google into Google, you can break the Internet. So please, no one try it.
Even for a joke.
It's not a laughing matter, you can break the internet.
Stimmt's?
Witz, das ist die Chefin der IT und sie weiß es aus guter Quelle.
Ja, ja, sie weiß wirklich Bescheid. Das ganze ist natürlich ein Zitat aus dem
großartigen und wundervollen und grandiosen Stück,
Serie, wie sagt man, aus der Serie, IT Crowd, genau.
Die, wenn ihr die nicht gesehen habt, ihr wahrscheinlich keine Hörer von LNP
seid und falls ihr doch das gerade hört und überhaupt nicht wisst wovon wir reden,
dann müsst ihr jetzt eigentlich auf Pause drücken und das einfach mal alles
komplett durchbingen, spätestens bis ihr da seid.
Das kann man ordnungsgemäß erwerben auf dem Internet, irgendwelche Gesetze. Kann man?
Ist das bei Netflix oder was?
Weiß gar nicht, ich hab's glaube ich mal bei Apple erworben oder so.
Okay.
Aber ich hab's definitiv, sozusagen legal im Zugriff und man muss da halt auch
immer mal wieder reinhören, weil's einfach die Wahrheit ist über alles.
Wie das so ist mit Standardwerken, man muss immer mal wieder drin blättern.
Genau, so sieht's aus. Das ist wirklich ein Handbuch. Zum Beispiel wenn ein Supportanruf kommt.
Ja, every threat is open again.
Eine absolute Treasure Trove, wie man so schön sagt. Also das ist einfach die
Wahrheit über Nerds und über Firmen und über die Kenntnisse über das Internet
im Allgemeinen, auch selbst in IT Abteilungen.
Aber es gibt einen guten Torrent dazu hier, naja.
Aber was ist denn jetzt wenn man Google bei Google eingibt, was passiert denn da jetzt wirklich?
Ich bin noch nicht verrückt.
Ich mach das jetzt, ich mach das jetzt.
Tim.
Doch, Google.
Na dann zeigen sie dir was, dann kriegst du Wikipedia Antrag zu Google,
also erstmal kriegst du die Webseite, kriegst du Google LLC.
Ja, da siehst du mal, wie die sich wieder bevorzugen. Der Google-Algorithmus,
die haben nämlich hier die ersten vier Treffer. Wenn man Google googelt,
sind die ersten vier Treffer Google. Das ist ja wieder typisch,
ey. Und erst der fünfte ist Wikipedia.
Die zeigen wir an.
Und dann der sechste ist wieder Google, der siebte ist Google,
der achte ist Google, der neunte ist Google, der zehnte ist Google.
Und da soll mir einer sagen, dass die nicht an den Suchmaschinenergebnissen experimentieren.
Hilf uns dabei, Google noch besser zu machen, sagt der Mensch.
Frage anzeigen. Wie häufig nutzt du die Google-Suche ungefähr?
Weniger als einmal pro Monat, mehrmals pro Monat, mehrmals pro Woche,
einmal pro Tag, mehrmals pro Tag. Das ist eine gute Frage. Chat-GPT.
Das ist Chat-GPT das Ausführen. Wir müssen einen Podcast machen.
Was ist denn deine Default-Suchmaschine? Google.
Wirklich?
Ja. Also ich, ähm, ich, tut mir leid, dass ich jetzt wieder tausend Nerd-Träume
zerstöre, weil ich nicht mit DuckDuckGo suche oder so.
Ähm, ne, Google. Ich benutze Google.
Also ich such, also meine Default-Suchmaschine ist tatsächlich DuckDuckGo. Mhm. Ähm.
Ich glaub ist auch gut, ist, ist, ist auch in Ordnung mit bestimmten Browsern,
Tor-Browser oder so, wo die vor eingestellt ist, ist das auch in Ordnung.
Das sind einfach auch okaye Suchergebnisse in den allermeisten Fällen.
Ich will keine okayen Suchergebnisse.
Naja okay heißt auch nicht so überladen mit Werbung und was Google meint,
was du erstmal anklicken solltest.
Bei Google hab ich keine Werbung.
Naja in den Suchergebnissen, die sind ja nicht unbedingt als Werbung markiert.
Doch sind sie, die Sponsoren Links sind als Werbung markiert und die funktionieren
bei mir alle nicht. Die werden vom DNS Blocker eh gefressen, die Tracking Links.
Das heißt das hab ich schon mir abgewöhnt, die Dings, ja ich guck mal irgendwie, wo ich meine.
Weil du so ein Leader Dude bist, funktioniert das für dich, aber das erinnert
mich an eine Tatsache, dass es durchaus Alternativen gibt.
Ich sag jetzt nicht, man muss die auf jeden Fall benutzen. Ich hab das einfach
bei mir generell als Default eingestellt und bin ehrlich gesagt nicht unzufrieden damit.
Ich kann, ich möchte auch nicht, ich möchte tatsächlich nicht jetzt irgendwie, also es ist meiner,
meiner mangelnden, meiner mangelnden awareness geschuldet, dass ich einfach mit google google.
Ist so.
Ja weiß was ich, bevor mir jetzt irgendwie,
weiß nicht ob alle sagen der Linus der googelt bei Google und nicht bei DuckDuckGo
oder so, ich weiß ja das ist ein Host höchst emotional geführte Debatten um
die Datenkrake gibt und so und ich mach das einfach ohne darüber nachzudenken.
Und nicht, nicht aus einer conscious decision, ich kann auch nicht sagen,
dass ich jetzt irgendwie schlechte Erfahrungen mit DuckDuckGo gemacht hätte.
Ich hab einfach nur noch nicht den Standard Browser, die Standardsuchmaschine
geändert in meinen Standard Browsern. Jetzt fragt nicht auch noch,
was mein Standard Browser ist. Der ist nicht von Google. Den benutze ich nicht.
Da bin ich, da bin ich ganz bei den Aluhüten.
Chrome benutze ich nicht.
Ich auch nicht, also nur in Ausnahmefällen.
Und Android benutze ich auch nicht, aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Doch Android benutze ich auch, ich habe ja ein Android Handy,
nur nicht für ein tägliches Telefon.
Warum reden wir überhaupt über Google? Du hast damit angefangen,
Google ist Vierteljahrhundert geworden.
25 Jahre ist es her und ich glaube das müsste dann auch in etwa 25 Jahre,
also was genau ist vor 25 Jahren passiert?
Ist das die Inkorporation der Firma oder ist das die Gründung der Firma? 4.
September 98. Also es war vor drei Tagen.
Also vor drei Tagen war es 25 Jahre her.
Vor drei Tagen war es 25 Jahre, ja.
Gut, aber die Suchmaschine Google gab es schon vorher.
Das kann ich nicht bestätigen oder denyen. Ich glaube,
also ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, dass es die vorher gab,
weil ich weiß, dass die, oder ich glaube die Legende Wille ist,
dass die ihre Suchmaschine eigentlich Gogol nennen wollten, nach der großen Zahl.
Und das jetzt aber der, ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das der Seljay Brin oder der Larry Page war,
irgendwie, der dem Kollegen oder der Kollegin irgendwie gesagt hat,
ja ja, registriere mal Google und dass das dann irgendwie falsch geschrieben
wurde oder so. Ich weiß aber auch wieder nicht, ob das stimmt.
Das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen, das ist aber auch nicht egal,
also ob sie das sozusagen absichtlich anders gemacht haben oder falsch,
ob das jetzt ein Wortspiel oder ein Rechtschreibfehler war, das ist glaube ich
nicht so richtig belegt.
Tatsache ist, unter dem Namen Google gibt's diese Suchmaschine schon seit dem 15.
September 97, also quasi seit 26 Jahren.
Und vorher gab es ein Vorläufer-System mit dem eleganten Namen BackRub.
Warum auch immer man sich da mit dem Rücken kräuseln muss.
Ob einem da sich der Rücken gekräuselt hat oder ob der nur einem gekrault wurde,
wir lassen das jetzt offen.
Tatsache ist, vorher war das quasi so als studentisches Projekt an der Stanford University.
Und ich meine, dass auch in dem Jahr,
jetzt hoffe ich, dass ich nicht durcheinander komme, hatten wir nämlich diesen
sagenumwobenen Anruf von Feefe, Chaos Radio, als wir uns über Suchmaschinen unterhalten haben.
Und der Patrank erklärt wurde.
Nee, da kam er überhaupt erstmal mit dem Thema auf und meinte so,
habt ihr das schon mal gehört, es gibt da noch so bei der Stanford University
gibt's noch so eine Suchmaschine, die heißt Google, die funktioniert irgendwie auch ganz geil.
Ja aber erklärt er dann nicht genau diesen Patron, dass nämlich die als Maßgabe
für die Relevanz einer Seite die Anzahl der Links genutzt haben?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob er das in dem Moment erklärt hat. Du warst ja dabei,
warum weißt du das nicht mehr? Mein Gott, das ist 26 Jahre her, ich bitte dich.
Jedenfalls, Google, die Suchmaschine leitet ihren Namen von Gogol ab,
angelehnt an das Bestreben möglichst viele Internetseiten zu indizieren.
Der Name des Firmenhauptsitzes lautet Googleplex in Anlehnung an GoGolplex.
Google verwendet eine an GoGol angelehnte Domain 1E100net für eigene Server.
Und 1E100 ist nämlich der GoGolplex, also die Zahl 10 hoch GoGol, also 10 hoch 100.
Ein GoGolplex ist eine Zahl mit 10 hoch 100 Nullen.
Das ist eine sehr große Zahl und die Zahl ist deutlich größer als die Anzahl
der Protonen im sichtbaren Universum.
Ja. Womit immer noch offen ist, ob es im nicht sichtbaren Universum noch mehr
gibt. Aber lassen wir das offen.
Ja, das könnt ihr ja dann euch gut vorstellen.
War Google damals einfach eine Revolution,
eben genau aus diesem Grund,
mit diesem PageRank, also der Ansatz quasi die Relevanz aus Verlinkungen herauszunehmen
und damit quasi auch schon das Netz ein wenig an seiner Substanz zu packen und
nicht einfach nur Text einzulesen und in irgendeiner Form durchsuchbar zu machen,
wie das die Suchmaschinen davor gemacht haben.
Also populär war ja vorher vor allem Alta Vista, das war so ein bisschen das Google der Zeit davor.
Gab auch noch ein paar andere Projekte, aber Alta Vista war so definitiv das,
was am meisten verwendet wurde. Nur da waren halt die Suchergebnisse wirklich
noch sehr, wie soll ich sagen, Glückssache in gewisser Hinsicht.
Aber da musste ja das ganze Prinzip überhaupt erstmal geboren werden und dann
haben halt Sergey Brin und Larry Page,
die haben dann halt irgendwie schnell herausgefunden, dass dann eben Relevanz
sich sehr viel besser daraus ablesen lässt, wie,
quasi das, die innere Struktur des Hypertext-Raums durch die Links,
das eben quasi selbst ermittelt und oder erzeugt.
Und genau das haben sie dann quasi als primäre Ordnungszahl genommen,
eben dieser Page-Rank, was sich auf Larry-Page bezieht, glaube ich, und nicht auf Seiten.
Und ja, das war dann so ein bisschen der Erfolg und dann hat es wirklich nicht
lange gedauert und Google hat einfach alles hinter sich gelassen und es gab
so recht kein anderes Suchmaschinenprojekt, was da mithalten konnte.
Bis dahin war ja sogar noch Yahoo halbwegs populär.
Bis dann irgendwann die Leute gecheckt haben, dass man so viel E-Mail echt nicht haben will.
Naja gut, also lange lange Zeit haben sie einfach, die Dienste,
die sie rausgebracht haben, waren einfach viel besser als alle anderen.
Google Reader, der so RSS Feeds, irgendwann haben sie dann angefangen all das,
was so ihr Business Modell wieder strebte, nämlich letzten Endes Werbung zu
verkaufen, dann irgendwie wieder klein zu halten.
Und seitdem ist es ein bisschen schwierig mit Google und dem Verhältnis der Nerds,
wobei ich glaube es ist ein Love-Hate-Relationship, was der gemeine Nerd mit
Google hat, weil Google schon auch the nerdiest company irgendwie ist.
In ihrem ganzen Auftreten, in ihrem Gehabe, in der Art und Weise wie sie dann
auch Leute rekrutiert haben,
was sie für ein Company Lifestyle an den Tag gelegt haben und generell ihre
Nähe zum Netz und ihr tiefes Verständnis des Netzes auch immer wieder in allen
Produkten haben zeigen können.
Also, und das war ja, ich hab ja noch nicht mal, also mit Gmail und der Google-Suche
ist ja noch lange nicht alles genannt, was totale Revolution war.
Womit sie glaube ich auch den
absoluten Mega-Hit gelandet haben bis zum heutigen Tage ist Google Maps.
Das war vom ganzen Ansatz her fantastisch,
alle Kartendienste die es bis dahin gab, die haben halt irgendwie gnadenlos mit,
oh ihr müsst aber auf unserer Seite rumklicken und wehe ihr baut irgendwie ein
Stück von unserer Karte in eurer Webseite ein und Google hat gesagt so ja,
macht doch, baut uns überall ein. Baut uns überall ein in eure Autos.
Wir haben einfach gecheckt, dass das eine geile Idee ist und vor allem haben
sie als erstes halt auch Javascript richtig verstanden.
Also ein Freund von mir war tatsächlich einer derjenigen,
die damals diese Javascript Engine gebaut haben für Google Maps,
also dieses ganze dynamische Nachladen der Kacheln, das war ja quasi das Novum schlechthin.
Du hattest also nicht einfach nur so eine Webseite, die dann irgendwie ewig gedauert hat,
bis sie sich aufbaut, sondern du hattest einfach so dieses dynamische Reinsumen
und dieses asynchrone Laden der Kacheln, das war quasi das große Ding und dass
du da so hin und her draggen konntest.
Das war unheard of, das gab's vorher irgendwie gar nicht.
Sie waren Bleeding Edge in Ihrem Webdevelopment, Sie waren Bleeding Edge in
der Auswahl der Dienste an sich,
was Sie angeboten haben, aber eben auch wie Sie es umgesetzt haben und auch
in vielen Bereichen, was für ein Businessmodell Sie da drumherum haben.
Gemacht haben. Muss man ihnen schon lassen und dadurch sind sie halt so groß
geworden und sind es immer noch.
Es gibt glaube ich noch so, wenn man jetzt nur ökonomisch drauf blickt,
waren die glaube ich nicht unbedingt so innovativ seit Gründung.
Ja also vieles ist auch dazu gekauft. Also ja Maps in Ordnung.
Bildsuche und so weiter. Aber das jetzt wirklich, wenn man jetzt so wirtschaftlich
drauf schaut. YouTube haben sie sich dazu gekauft.
Gmail ist jetzt keine, nix was denen viel Geld einbringt oder so.
Android haben sie gekauft. Ja aber das Argument verstehe ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Also gerade der Kauf von YouTube zeigt doch, dass sie das Businessmodell verstanden
haben. Also als sie YouTube gekauft haben, haben sie ja kein Businessmodell gekauft.
Ja, aber die Innovation kam nicht mehr von Ihnen. Das ist das, was ich meine.
Wenn du jetzt guckst, welche Innovation ist bei Google entstanden?
Es ist eine Suchmaschine von dem vierten Jahrhundert. Da haben sie sich einen
Video-Hoster dazu gekauft,
dann haben sie die Karten, also Maps und Earth gemacht, mit denen sie aber,
glaube ich, nicht unbedingt quasi innovativ mehr Geld verdienen.
Google News, E-Mail und so.
Dann haben sie mehrere, auch wirklich klägliche Versuche versucht soziale Netzwerke
zu bauen, die ihnen nicht gelügt sind.
Ork Hut, Buzz, Google Plus oder Plus One oder so, die hatten die beste Möglichkeit,
dann haben sie ja Google Hangouts, ja Google Talk, das ist, also ich weiß, keine Ahnung.
Die Liste der Fails ist groß, aber auf der anderen Seite, ja.
Und was nicht dabei ist, ist in dem vierten Jahrhundert eine neue fette Idee
wie die Google Suche, das ist mein Argument.
Der Browser, okay, ja, aber dann haben sie im Prinzip pflegen sie so weiter.
Und das was große fette neue Märkte sind, die sie sich verschafft haben, sind Zukunft.
Die haben also keine neuen fetten Dinge selber geschaffen, während sie da in
ihren Bällebädern sitzen.
Also ist eine Definitionsfrage.
Lass mich doch mal kurz erläutern warum ich das anders sehe.
Also YouTube dazu gekauft, ja meinetwegen und sie hatten ja parallel dazu Google Video.
Sie haben sehr wohl verstanden, dass Video ein großes Ding ist und ich kann
mich noch sehr sehr sehr lebhaft daran erinnern, als sie den Kauf von YouTube verkündet haben,
Wie einfach alle im Internet sich gefragt haben, was zur Hölle wollen sie mit YouTube.
Ja und als Elon Musk Twitter gekauft hat, haben sich auch alle gefragt,
was will der damit und niemand hat gesagt, das zeigt aber echt mal,
was für einen innovativen Geist Elon Musk hat.
Das ist doch, jetzt kommen wir nicht mit Elon Musk. Also, bleiben wir,
nein, guck mal, du hast gerade gesagt, sie sind nicht gut in Social Networks, das stimmt nicht.
Weil mit YouTube sind sie eins, das ist eins der größten Social Networks.
Das ist eins der erfolgreichsten und eins der profitabelsten Social Networks,
die es gibt neben Facebook.
Du meinst die Kommentarspalte unter den Videos?
Das ist ein Social Network. Leute präsentieren sich dort mit ihrem Inhalten
und kommentieren sich gegenseitig.
Wir hätten aber doch jetzt schon mehrmals festgestellt, dass sie das gekauft
haben und nicht selber entwickelt haben.
Was sie gekauft haben ist das Webseitenprodukt und das gut, das korrekt gelungene
Design, wo eine Community angebissen hat, aber sie hatten quasi den Blick dafür,
Zu sehen, dass das ein fettes Teil ist.
Ja, das ist äußerst schlau, was die Marketing oder die Mergers and Acquisitions
Abteilung von Google da geleistet hat.
Aber nochmal, die sitzen da irgendwie in ihren Bällebädern, ja.
Und man muss dem Unternehmen, also in einem vierten Jahrhundert gab es eine
Reihe an zentralen Innovationen, die das Internet weitergebracht haben.
Large Language Models gerade das nächste große Thema,
warum man auch, wie gesagt, aus einer wirtschaftlichen Perspektive echt mal gucken kann,
dass dieses Unternehmen kein, also wie kann es sein,
dass das im Prinzip Open AI aus dem Nichts herauskommt, mit ein bisschen Investment
von unterschiedlichen Tech Giganten.
Jetzt alle darüber diskutieren, dass das das ganz große nächste Ding ist und
Google da steht und irgendwie Hose runter hat und irgendeinem komischen Bart
oder sowas da ankommt, wo sich alle drüber Schrott lachen, weil der in dritten
Satz irgendwie den Holocaust leugnet oder so.
Also da sind die, die sind nicht besonders weit vorne, was die Innovationen,
technische und wirtschaftliche Innovationen angeht, seit dieser einen Suchmaschine.
Man hat auch nicht so einen hohen Innovationsdruck, wenn man 60 Milliarden Gewinn
macht oder Umsatz oder was auch immer der Google Umsatz ist.
Jetzt auch mal kurz Google Jahresgewinn.
Ja, was setzen die um?
Nettogewinn 18 Milliarden.
Okay gut, du bist im Randmodus, ich finde auch in dem AI… Das hat nichts mit
Rand zu tun, Tim, das sind einfach nur Fakten.
Fakten kann man, ist auch eine Frage der Perspektive, ja? Ne,
jetzt fangen wir nicht mit alternativen Fakten an. Lass mich doch mal einen
Satz zu Ende aussprechen.
Wenn du jetzt sagst Open AI hat irgendwie abgeräumt, also ob die businessmäßig
hier wirklich abräumen, das wird sich erst noch zeigen.
Und im Bereich AI, wer hat denn, also da hat Google die großen Schritte gemacht
in den letzten Jahren. Der ganze Durchbruch von Machine Learning ist letzten
Endes auf YouTube passiert.
Mit dem Anstellen von dem Joffrey hinten, der letzten Endes den Durchbruch im
Machine Learning gebracht hat. Den haben sie sich sofort ins Haus geholt,
als der sein Paper rausgehauen hat.
Und es war Youtube wohl das erste Mal Large Scale Machine Learning bewiesen
hat, dass es eben funktioniert, dass man eben irgendwie alle Katzenbilder im
Internet erkennen kann.
Weil sie die Daten haben und weil sie es auch haben und die Demonstrationen,
die sie mit ihren AI Systemen ganz zu Anfang schon gemacht haben, ich sag nur AlphaGo, ja,
Diese ganze Alpha Geschichte war super erfolgreich und Bahnbrechen und hat letzten
Endes für die AI, die LLMs, die wir heute haben im Prinzip den Weg bereitet. Also ist halt so.
Und nochmal, also weil du es ja glaube ich auch jetzt absichtlich nicht mehr
hören oder nicht mehr verstehst, DeepMind haben sie am 23.
September 2010, ne im Moment da wurde es gegründet, ein paar Jahre,
irgendwie 2014 haben sie DeepMind gekauft.
Auch da im Prinzip, mein Argument ist,
die haben keine Inhouse-Innovationen, die bahnbrechend irgendwas gemacht hat
und du kannst natürlich sagen,
dass die Zukäufe von besonderer Vision sind, aber ich glaube,
mein Argument lasse ich jetzt dadurch zumindest nicht verfälschen,
dass von denen nichts Großartiges mehr gekommen ist in letzter Zeit.
Und die haben aber genug Geld, um sich im Prinzip derartiges zu leisten.
Wer 20 Milliarden Gewinn macht im Jahr, kann eine ganze Menge dazukaufen.
Und damit sind wir ja auch bei dem Problem, was passiert,
wenn solche Gigantenunternehmen entstehen,
dass sie sich eine ganze Reihe an Konkurrenz und sonstigen neuen Produkten und
so weiter einverleiben können und dann irgendwann ja die die die Fantasie in greifbarer Nähe haben,
eine Plattform zu sein und nicht mehr nur die beste Suchmaschine oder das beste
Navigationssystem, sondern, so wie es sich Google eben über diese Zeit entwickelt hat.
Betriebssystem für dein mobiles Endgerät zu liefern, den Browser,
ein komplettes Arbeitsökosystem mit Google Docs, was übrigens,
das glaube ich, da waren sie mal richtig weit vorne, was kollaboratives Arbeiten angeht.
Da hätten sie eine Chance sogar gehabt, Microsoft richtig was wegzunehmen.
Dann hat Microsoft aber sein Office gerettet.
Den mit dem Chromebook versuchen sie ja auch quasi,
die Google-Plattform zu sein und in gewissen Umgebungen, in gewissen Arbeitsumfeldern
ist ihnen das durchaus gelungen.
Das ist ja das, was diese großen Unternehmen eben anstreben,
dich da drin irgendwie gefangen zu nehmen und alternativlos zu werden.
Und das ist das, was Apple natürlich auch versucht mit iOS,
iPadOS als Plattform mit allen integrierten Diensten so in dein Leben verwoben,
mit einem Voice Assistant und Gerät und so weiter, dass du in diesem Ökosystem dann gefangen bist.
Und das ist, denke ich, das, was der wahrhaft zu kritisieren oder der wahrhaft
beängstigende Faktor an derartigen Unternehmen ist, dass sie einfach zu mächtig werden.
Wer zu viel Geld hat, kann sich dann irgendwann auch aus der Konkurrenz gewissermaßen
rauskaufen Und hat dann eine marktbeherrschende Stellung,
die problematisch ist.
Nicht nur aus Gründen der mangelnden Konkurrenz oder vielleicht geschluckten Innovationskraft,
sondern insbesondere, wenn man im Auge behält, dass das fundamentale Geschäftsmodell,
also der große Teil, womit Google Geld verdient.
Und jetzt vorsichtig sage ich den Begriff, ist Verhaltensbeeinflussung,
ja ich sage extra Beeinflussung, um nicht zu sagen Manipulation,
aber im Prinzip verdienen Google und auch Facebook natürlich,
ebenso wie Twitter, die verdienen alle ihr Geld damit, die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass Menschen etwas bestimmtes tun, etwas bestimmtes klicken,
etwas bestimmtes kaufen zu erhöhen, nur deswegen zahlen Leute bei denen für Werbung.
Und wenn du jetzt halt irgendwie ein Unternehmen hast, was de facto mit Verhaltensbeeinflussung
Milliarden verdient und das irgendwie weltweit,
ist das eine krasse Abweichung von der ursprünglichen Sache.
Eine geile Suchmaschine bauen.
Wir erinnern uns vielleicht noch an das Urspielmotto dieses Unternehmens.
Das haben sie irgendwann gestrichen, ne? Don't be evil.
Genau, das haben sie dann doch eingesehen, dass einfach nicht evil sein keine Option ist.
Ich glaube sie haben sich nicht offiziell davon verabschiedet,
sie haben nur gesagt wir schreiben das jetzt nicht mehr so groß hin.
Ich habe irgendwie so was...
Hahaha so dieses... das Motto offiziell zu sagen so,
ah ey kleine Änderung, übrigens liebe Aktien Besitzerinnen dieses mit dem don't be evil,
das streichen wir jetzt das haben sie das haben sie dann auch gecheckt dass
das vielleicht nicht nicht so geil ist Ich glaube das war irgendwie so,
ja nee, wir schreiben jetzt was anderes hin.
Also die Wikipedia meint, es ist das ehemalige Motto und immer noch ein Satz,
der in Googles corporate code of conduct drin auftaucht,
aber Alphabet sozusagen, die überspannende Firmengruppe, Die hat sich als Motto
do the right thing gewählt.
Is this good for the company?
Ja, naja, also auf jeden Fall man kann jetzt nicht, also ich hab ja fast das
Gefühl ich komm hier schon als Google Fanboy rüber,
das bin ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr, das bin ich vielleicht mal für
eine Zeit lang mit gewesen, so zusammen mit dem ganzen anderen Internet,
als das alles noch sehr solide und interessant und neu und aufregend war.
Aber, ähm, ja, Google ist nicht so bei mir ganz oben auf der Liste von Sachen,
die ich jetzt wirklich total verabscheue, so, aber ich bin halt definitiv jetzt
auch Kind-Fanboy von Google, mir gefällt nicht alles, was sie machen.
Aber es ist auch nicht so, dass mir jetzt gar nichts gefallen würde,
was sie hier machen, da habe ich ein sehr gespaltenes Verhältnis zu dem Laden,
wie viele wahrscheinlich von uns.
Ich glaube, das kann ich auch sagen. Ich sehe größere Probleme, die wir gerade haben.
Könnte man jetzt auch sogar sagen, wenn man jetzt mal die Tech-Giganten nimmt
und sortiert sie nach ihrer schädlichen Wirkung,
ist Google auf jeden Fall nicht ganz oben, heißt aber nicht,
dass sie jetzt besonders geil werden oder so.
Gut, soviel dazu, happy birthday sagt man wahrscheinlich, naja,
alt ist seid ihr ja schon 26.
Ja, okay, dann kommen wir zum Feedback.
Ja genau, Feedback hatten wir, das haben wir letztes mal noch ein bisschen rausgelassen,
es gab ein schönes Feedback zu unserer vorletzten Sendung mit Julian Hesenthaler.
Ein etwas längerer Kommentar von Iveri, den kann ich unmöglich komplett wiedergeben,
aber vielleicht zwei Aspekte davon. Zunächst einmal geht's generell um Österreich
und vor allem erstmal um die Steiermark.
Als geborener Grazer und Walinzer fühle ich mich geradezu verpflichtet,
hier zu kommentieren. Wie Tim schon richtig festgestellt hat,
ist das steirische Kürbiskernöl ein sehr beliebtes Genussmittel in und um Graz.
Dabei handelt es sich in seiner Exklusivität quasi um den Champagner Österreichs.
Der eben genannte Schaumwein darf bekanntlicher nur so genannt werden,
wenn er in der Champagner hergestellt wurde und das gilt auch für das steirische
Kürbiskernöl und die Steiermark.
Allerdings kommt mittlerweile ein guter Teil der verwendeten Kürbiskerne aus
anderen Bundesländern wie Niederösterreich.
Buh, das was um Wien herum ist. Soweit ist es mit der Qualität also auch nicht hin.
Dafür gibt es mit dem Cucurbita pepo varstiriaca oder steirischen Ölkürbis eine
eigene Kürbisart für die Ölherstellung.
Kürbiskernöl in Cola kenne ich bisher nicht. Allerdings gibt es einen Eisbecher
mit Kürbiskernöl, den man als steirische Sünde bezeichnet. Der Name ist Programm.
Ich finde, es schmeckt absolut ekelhaft.
Steirische Sünde. Das stimmt. Dann hebt der Kommentar noch weiter ab,
um irgendwie eine Generalumschreibung Österreichs zu liefern,
mit all seiner geografischen Ausprägungen.
Das lasse ich jetzt mal weg und komme hier auf das Beziehungsgeflecht, was er noch hervorhebt.
Beziehungen sind wichtig, aber in Österreich vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr.
Vitamin B, wie man es nennt, zu verwenden, ist nichts Ungewöhnliches und wird
gemeinhin auch nicht als verwerflich angesehen, weil das ist heut einmal so.
Dabei spielt es dann auch keine Rolle, ob es um die Umwidmung zum Baugrundstück
beim lokalen Bürgermeister geht oder um den Aufsichtsratsvorsitz eines staatsnahen Konzerns.
Ein Thema, was bei einem Umriss der politischen Landschaft Österreichs nicht
fehlen darf, Die Bundesländer Österreich ist wie Deutschland ein Bundesstaat
mit neun Ländern und vereint hierbei das Schlechteste aus beiden Welten.
De facto ist Österreich nämlich eher ein Zentralstaat mit bundesstaatlichen Elementen.
Die Länder verfügen nur über wenige und kaum relevante Kompetenzen,
sowas wie Jagdordnung und Jugendschutz werden hier oft genannt,
viel mehr ist es dann aber eh nicht. Dafür verfügen die Länder bzw.
Landeshauptleute über enorme informelle Macht. Hier sei beispielsweise die Landeshauptleutekonferenz
genannt, bei der es sich meines Wissens um gar kein offizielles Organ,
sondern vielmehr um ein inoffizielles Treffen der Landeshauptleute handelt.
Trotzdem glaube ich nicht, dass eine Bundesregierung auch nur irgendein Gesetz
beschließen könnte, wogegen sich die Landeshauptleutekonferenz geschlossen sträubt. Naja.
Ich finde noch den, den, äh, abschließend möchte ich diesen Kommentar mit einem
alten Witz aus der Kaiserzeit, Ein deutscher und ein österreichischer General
analysieren am Vortag der Schlacht die Lage.
Der Deutsche sagt, die Lage ist ernst, aber nicht hoffnungslos.
Der Österreicher antwortet, die Lage ist hoffnungslos, aber nicht ernst.
Vielleicht ein schöner Mentalitätsvergleich.
Vielen Dank für diesen Kommentar, könnt ihr nochmal nachlesen,
ist bei uns natürlich alles verlinkt.
So, dann haben wir verschiedene Kommentare zum Selbstbestimmungsgesetz.
Da haben die meisten sich darüber gefreut, dass wir das Thema behandelt haben.
Waren auch mehrere Leute dabei, die sich von dem Thema konkret persönlich betroffen sehen.
Und dann gab es zu dem Thema Untertauchen ein Kommentar von S.
Erstens, es gibt zahlreiche Länder, die Selbstbestimmungsgesetze haben.
Circa 100 Millionen Menschen in Europa haben bereits ähnliche Möglichkeiten
in dem Land, in dem sie leben.
Europa ist noch nicht in Chaos versunken, weil Kriminelle aus diesen Ländern
massenweise ihren Vornamen und Geschlechtseintrag ändern und untertauchen.
Das Beispiel mag auf den ersten Blick plausibel klingen, tritt aber praktisch nicht auf.
Zweitens, es wäre sowieso nur in den Fällen relevant, in denen gegen die Person,
die untertauchen möchte, zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht ermittelt wird.
Es spricht ja, soweit ich das einschätzen kann, nichts dagegen,
dass dies zum Zeitpunkt der Anpassung durch die Standesämter geprüft wird.
Finde ich einen wichtigen Hinweis.
Die Kritik richtet sich, zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung, hauptsächlich gegen
die proaktive Übertragung der Daten an zahlreiche Behörden.
Eine datensparsamere Variante wäre die aktuelle Handhabung, bei der ein rechtliches
Interesse glaubhaft gemacht werden kann, um die Verknüpfung vom alten zum neuen
Datensatz zu offenbaren. Also hier ist ein Kompromiss-Idee.
Außerdem solltest du als Beliehner eigentlich wissen, dass man fürs spontane
Untertauchen eh nicht schnell genug einen Termin beim Standesamt bekommt,
auch unabhängig von der drei Monate Frist im Entwurf.
Auch dieser Kommentar geht ein bisschen länger, aber ich denke,
da wird nochmal den wichtigen Teil habe ich hier erfasst.
Dann, zu Patientenakte. Auch mehrere Kommentare und wir haben da jetzt unsere
Zwiespältigkeit ja geschildert,
dass so ein schönes Datenmodell durchaus helfen könnte, wenn es vernünftig abgesichert
wäre, gleichzeitig der Bedarf sich uns beiden als bisher noch halbwegs gesunde
Leute noch nicht so zeigt.
Da hatte ich ja auch in der letzten Sendung auf einen Kommentar verwiesen,
den wir schon vor längerer Zeit einmal hatten und entsprechend gibt es mehrere.
Da kommentiert Name, sag ich es gleich am Ende. Nur mal von meiner Seite die
Perspektive zu euren Kommentaren zur elektronischen Patientenakte.
Ich möchte nochmals betonen, was für ein Segen das sein kann.
Ich selber habe einiges an chronischen Krankheiten und muss um die 10 bis 13
Mal im Jahr allein aus Routine zu verschiedenen Ärzten,
denen jedes Mal über alles andere zu berichten nimmt unglaublich viel Zeit in
Anspruch, dazu kommt Umzug zwischen Städten ist ein Albtraum,
weil ohne E-Akte dann Berge an Papier und Befunden zu neuen Ärzten geschleppt werden müssen.
Ja, die E-Akte wird nicht gut umgesetzt werden und ja,
das ist echt traurig, aber selbst ich als jemand,
der gute IT-Security für notwendig hält und sich als Privacy-affin bezeichnen
würde, wäre bereit, etwas laxere Privacy und Security hinzunehmen,
wenn es mir zugutekommen könnte, wie es das Konzept verspricht.
Zudem ermöglicht es auf lange Sicht auch Wiederholungsrezepte,
die zum Beispiel für ein Jahr gültig sind. Man denke ja nur an alte Menschen,
die wenige in der Packung Blutdrucksenker zum Arzt rennen müssen.
Was auch gerne vergessen wird, oftmals hängen viele Diagnosen zusammen und beeinflussen
sich gegenseitig, auch über Fachgebiete hinaus.
So kann sich zum Beispiel ein physisches Leiden auf die Depressionswahrscheinlichkeit
auswirken, Solche Daten sind im bisherigen System nicht wirklich gut aggregiert.
Hat man sie jedoch alle beisammen, lässt sich vieles leichter und auch besser
behandeln beziehungsweise nach Ursachen forschen. Ich finde,
hier sollte die Debatte tatsächlich praktischer geführt werden mit dem Fokus
auf iterative Verbesserung.
Auch wenn es eigentlich kein guter Ansatz ist, sind hier die Chancen einfach
so unglaublich hoch, dass man ein paar Risiken in Kauf nehmen kann.
Kommentiert ODR. Ich verlinke euch auch noch mal einen Kommentar von Jörn,
der den Krankenhausalltag schildert,
wie viel Zeit auf das Herstellen von Kontakten zwischen Ärzten und Patienten verwendet wird,
die Weitergabe und so weiter, sodass er da auf eine Effizienzsteigerung im Prozess
hofft, die den Patientinnen zugutekommt.
Schön ist, dann muss der CCC als unabhängige Kontrollinstanz eben wieder den
Penetrationstest übernehmen. Ja, nee, also den können die schon selber bezahlen bei irgendjemandem.
Dafür sind wir nicht da. Und wenn die alle durch sind und die offensichtlichen
Schwachstellen out of scope definiert wurden, dann gucken wir mal drauf.
Aber das ist nichts, worauf ich finde, auf das gesetzt werden soll.
Da ist aber auch Smiley an dem Satz drin.
Ja stimmt. Aber wichtig finde ich auch noch den Hinweis, ach und Deutschland
ist in Sachen Digitalisierung kein Entwicklungsland.
Meine Frau kommt aus einem Entwicklungsland und selbst dort benutzt man keinen Fax mehr.
Deswegen habe ich ja von der digitalen dritten Welt gesprochen.
Ja genau.
So kommen wir zu ärgerlicheren Themen. Achso sollen wir noch einen ganz kurzen
kleinen Scherz einbringen, bevor wir zu ernsten Themen kommen.
Scherz? In dieser Sendung?
Nee, es ist eigentlich kein Scherz, aber Elon Musk hat offenbar ein längeres
Interview geführt und da dann ein bisschen frei geredet und hat sich dann da
auch ein bisschen dazu geäußert,
dass er Twitter gekauft hat und erzählt,
also wie gesagt, das ist ein bisschen länger hergeleitet, aber sagt dann so seine Tochter,
Jenna, die im Alter von 16 Jahren die Transition hatte zu dem weiblichen Geschlecht,
da war er sehr stolz drauf, aber die hat dann im weiteren Verlauf ihres Lebens
ihn komplett aus ihrem Leben ausgeschlossen.
Und er sagt, dass das daran liegt, dass sie erstens zu einer radikalen Transformation
gekommen ist auf einer Privatschule mit 50.000.
US-Dollar Tuition-Fee, also der hat ihr quasi auf eine von radikalen Linken
betriebene, schweineteure Privatschule
geschickt, Wo sie dann mit dem Woke Mind Virus infiziert wurde.
Und dieses Woke Mind Virus kommt quasi von Twitter. Also da wurde das inkubiert.
Und sie hat sich dann von einer linksliberalen Sozialistin bis zu einer vollen
Kommunistin entwickelt.
Die glaubt, dass jeder der reich ist böse ist.
Und genau weil dieses Virus eben auf Twitter inkubiert wurde,
hat er dann gesagt, das Problem muss man lösen.
Weil dort Rechtsrechte und Anti-Establishment-Stimmen unterdrückt werden,
deswegen hat er dann Twitter gekauft.
Also ich glaube der hat einfach nur mal wieder irgendein Medikament genommen,
was ihm nicht verschrieben wurde, aber ja.
Den Eindruck hab ich allerdings auch. Oh man ey, Vogue Mind Virus. Gott, ey.
Genau, jetzt hat er sie jetzt so zuerst gehabt, ja. Ja, okay.
Gut, dann wissen wir, wer uns die Scheiße eingetreten hat. Ja?
Hätte Jenna doch einfach mal ab und zu mit ihrem scheißreichen Vater geredet,
Es wäre uns vieles erspart gewesen.
Aber ich glaube 50.000 Dollar im Jahr, eine Schule in den USA ist jetzt auch nicht.
Ich würde vermuten, dass das pro Semester ist und nicht pro Jahr.
Also so super Elite klingt das jetzt noch nicht, ich denke so die richtigen
Zahlen sind wahrscheinlich teurer, ne?
Ja ich sag ja, das wird da von irgendwelchen Kommunisten betrieben,
das ist eine absolute Lugakule.
Von irgendwelchen arbeitsscheuen linksliberalen Klimaschützern,
die ja oft zu viel auf Twitter rumgehangen haben. Ist doch klar,
dass der irgendwann mal was machen muss.
Also aber es ist wirklich absurd, ja also Thema, also nur um noch mal daran
zu erinnern, warum das in der Regel nicht gut ist, wenn zu viel Kapital auf
einem Haufen ist und zu wenig Kontrolle darüber herrscht, ja?
Es ist weder gut, wenn das irgendwie dem Shareholder Value geopfert wird,
noch ist es gut, wenn das irgendwie in den Händen von langsam vor sich hin sich
entwickelnden Psychotika ist.
Also das ist alles nicht gut. Besser, wenn ihr das Geld verteilt, zum Beispiel an uns, so.
Werdet auch nicht so reich, bitte. Gerade wenn ihr reich seid,
dann kann es einfach sein, dass ihr dann evil seid.
Ja genau, Liebe an uns.
Und don't be evil.
Also noch gehen Tims Kinder nicht auf Privatschulen mit 50.000 Euro Tuition Fee,
wenn es soweit ist sagen wir euch Bescheid und wenn die dann mit dem woke mind
virus infiziert sind, dann habt ihr was Gutes getan.
Sagen wir Bescheid, sagen wir Bescheid.
Es ist schon ein bisschen traurig.
Ja in der Tat.
Aber auch unterhaltsam, es ist halt unterhaltsam.
Kommen wir zu einem anderen Unternehmen, das beschlossen hat nicht evil zu sein.
Ja das ist hier, also das ist jetzt der Themenkomplex Chatkontrolle.
Und ich will da mal ein kleines Update zumachen. Und auch das hatten wir hier
längere Zeit diskutiert.
Ich glaube, wahrscheinlich ungefähr vor einem Jahr.
Ich meine, das war so vor einem Jahr ungefähr, dass Apple angekündigt hat,
dass sie im Prinzip Inhalte-Scanning machen möchten auf den Geräten.
Und dass im Prinzip von dem, was eine Chat-Kontrolle-Regel ist,
Regulierung verlangen würde, nicht zu unterscheiden ist.
Und wir haben hier, ich erinnere mich an eine gute Debatte,
wo Tim dann nämlich sagte, das findet er toll, dass Apple jetzt innovativ der
Sache entgegentritt, Weil die Motivation von Apple war, dass sie nicht die iCloud
kontrollieren wollten.
Sie sagten, die Daten, die da sind, sind Ende-zu-Ende verschlüsselt und die
wollen wir gar nicht kontrollieren können.
Und jetzt bauen wir nur für Child Sexual Abuse Material, also für CSAM,
Scanner, um das bekämpfen zu können.
Während wir die vollständige sonstige Privatsphäre der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer
aufrechterhalten. So war das Argument von Apple.
Jetzt kommt aber Apple zu dem Schluss und sagt,
wir können nichts für die Nutzerinnen sicherstellen,
dass ein Werkzeug für eine Art der Überwachung nicht umgewandelt wird,
um andere Inhalte zu überwachen, wie politische Aktivitäten und religiöse Verfolgung.
Aus diesem Grund geht jetzt der, wie heißt der,
ein Name,
die sagen, es ist praktisch unmöglich, automatische Scans mit Privatsphäre und
Sicherheit zu vereinen und aus diesem Grund stellen wir dieses Projekt ein und machen das nicht.
Erik Neuenschwander heißt der Mensch. Ja genau, der war der.
Und was ist seine Position?
Seine Position ist Direktor für Privatsphäre und Kinderschutz bei Apple.
Das ist krass, oder? Also die haben, das finde ich jetzt schon,
genau hier sehe ich es jetzt, da ist der Name, Erik Neuenschwander,
der hat also jetzt gesagt, hier tut mir leid, wir haben das versucht,
wir haben geguckt und wir haben festgestellt, dass das nicht sinnvoll umsetzbar
ist und aus diesem Grund lassen wir das jetzt sein.
Genau, also was sie konkret sein lassen ist die vorgeschlagene Funktion auf
dem Device mit einem speziellen Inhalte,
jetzt muss ich erstmal ein bisschen nachdenken,
also mit einem speziellen Algorithmus über die Bilder rüber zu gehen,
der quasi den Inhalt des Bildes quasi hascht,
Aber nicht sozusagen die Datei muss identisch sein, sondern ein Algorithmus,
der quasi auch ein Resizing und Stretching und Cropping und so weiter eines Bildes überlebt.
Da gibt es entsprechende Papers, dass das wohl irgendwie funktioniert.
Und dann damit quasi so ein Identifier erzeugt und ein vergleichbarer Identifier
wird bei einer, wie hieß noch gleich diese Behörde, weißt du das gerade?
Necmec. Aber das geht ja darüber hinaus.
Genau, dass die sozusagen mit dem Bildmaterial, was bekannt ist,
diesen selben Algorithmus durchführen und dann auf Basis dieses Identifiers das feststellen.
Was sie trotzdem machen, was in diesem Brief, der hier zitiert wird,
ja auch nochmal erwähnt wird, ist, dass sie ja zahlreiche automatische Erkennungsdinger
einbauen ins Telefon, die halt nur so Notifications machen, ne was weiß ich.
Kriegst irgendwie Penisfoto geschickt und dann erkennt die Software das und
dann ist das erstmal geblurrt und dann kann man das eben so einstellen für die
Kinder, dass dann irgendwie auch ne Warnung an die Eltern rausgeht,
also solche Mechanismen bauen sie noch.
Aber wovon sie sich jetzt explizit entfernt haben,
ist eben konkret diese Funktion, die in irgendeiner Form einen Abgleich mit
einer zentralen Behörde oder Institution vornimmt auf Basis Daten Dritter.
Und da haben sie jetzt quasi den Turnaround gemacht und diesen Vorschlag zurückgezogen.
Und dass sie nicht die iCloud durchsuchen wollen, wie das ja andere Anbieter
tun, das haben sie ja von vornherein gesagt und daran hat sich auch nichts geändert.
So, jetzt, also nur mal um zu sagen, also Apple sagt, wir können so etwas,
diese Form der Überwachung nicht machen, ohne die Privatsphäre zu verletzen,
deswegen lassen wir es sein.
Großbritannien verfolgt die Chat-Kontrolle mit der sogenannten Online-Safety-Bill,
auch das hatten wir diskutiert, wo ebenfalls automatische Inhalte-Kontrolle drinsteht,
die Darstellung von Kindesmissbrauch aufspüren soll und sie haben gesagt,
sie setzen das jetzt aus, zumindest so lange,
bis es technisch machbar ist und sagen,
eine Anordnung kann nur erfolgen, wenn die dies technisch machbar ist und die
Technologie nachweist,
sich Mindeststandards an Genauigkeit bei der Erkennung ausschließlich von Inhalten
zum sexuellen Missbrauch und zur Ausbeutung von Kindern erfüllt.
Zumindest erkennen sie an, dass die Technologie es zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht tut.
Und ich habe ja, glaube ich, auch mehrmals erklärt, dass es aufgrund der Zweideutigkeit
der Inhalte auch gar nicht funktionieren kann.
Das aber nur hintendran, zumindest sagen sie, bis dahin, also solange es das
nicht gibt, können wir es auch nicht anordnen, dass man es macht und ich bleibe
dabei, das wird es nie geben.
Wunderschönes Beispiel erzählen und das ist ganz einfach, Urlaubsfotos,
was weiß ich, Vater schickt Urlaubsfotos an Mutter, auf den Urlaubsfotos ist
das Kind nackt am Strand.
Es ergibt sich nur aus dem Kontext, dass das gerade die Eltern austauschen,
dass es sich dabei nicht, um eine CSAM handelt,
während würde das exakt gleiche Bild von mir aus an eine andere Person gehen
oder von jemand anderem in die falschen Hände geraten, wäre das exakt gleiche
Bild eben problematisch.
Das heißt, du brauchst nicht nur das Bild selbst, sondern auch noch den Kommunikationskontext dazu.
Und auch da, den kannst du noch fehlerhafter erkennen und umso problematischer
wird es. Deswegen denke ich, dass es nicht lösbar ist. Und immerhin haben sie
erkannt, dass es zumindest bis jetzt nicht gelöst ist.
Deswegen platzt diese Chat-Kontrolle in Großbritannien.
Übrigens, um nochmal kurz auf den Brief von Apple einzugehen,
das fand ich nämlich auch ziemlich bemerkenswert,
also nicht nur, dass sie sich quasi gegen ihren ursprünglichen Vorschlag entschieden haben,
sondern in diesem Brief übernehmen sie auch ziemlich umfänglich die Argumentation der,
ich sag mal, kritisierenden Institutionen, die an dieser ganzen Debatte teilgenommen
haben in den letzten Monaten und schreiben,
Unter anderem Scanning-Systeme sind auch nicht narrensicher und es gibt dokumentierte
Beweise von anderen Plattformen,
dass unschuldige Personen in dystopische Schleppnetze geraten sind,
die sie zu Opfern gemacht haben, obwohl sie nichts weiter getan haben,
als ganz normale und angemessene Bilder ihrer Babys zu teilen.
Wir erinnern uns an den Fall, den wir hier besprochen haben,
wo ein Vater ein Foto seines Kindes dem Kinderarzt geschickt hat und dafür von
Google für sein Leben lang gebannt wurde. Das ist hart.
Also der darf noch googlen, allerdings sich nicht mehr einloggen.
Und diese Fälle, die wir hier auch behandelt haben, sehen wir.
Dystopische Schleppnetze. Schleppnetze. Ist ein Zungenbrecher.
Dystopische Schleppnetze. Dystopian Dragnetze. Schön. So. Dann gibt es in Europa
eine ganze Menge Widerspruch zur Chatkontrolle.
Da hat jetzt Edry mal zusammengetragen die ganzen Stellungnahmen von allen möglichen
unterschiedlichen Verbänden und sagen ist this the most criticized draft EU law of all time.
Also ist es das am meisten kritisierte Gesetzesvorhaben aller Zeiten.
Und die haben die so ein bisschen geklastert, sagen,
okay, junge Menschen, dann Betroffene von Kindesmissbrauch,
also Child Sexual Abuse Survivors,
dann Kinderrechte- und Kinderschutzexpertinnen und Experten,
Polizei und Strafverfolger, Technologieexperten, ist natürlich die längste oder
eine der längsten Liste, unabhängige juristische Analysen, die also quasi sagen,
das geht auch gar nicht, grundrechtspassend,
dann.
Nationale Regierungen und Parlamente und das Europäische Parlament.
Dann Firmen, Privacy-Tech-Firmen, die Vereinten
Nationen, professionelle Geheimhaltungsorganisationen, klingt jetzt irre,
aber damit meinen sie halt so Journalistinnen und Anwältinnenverbände,
die Zivilgesellschaft, das sind jeweils sind ja so immer mindestens drei bis
keine Ahnung, 15 Einzelstellungen nahmen, die sich alle gegen diese Chat-Kontrolle setzten.
Zuletzt ein offener Brief der Wissenschaft, die also sagen, die Technologien
zur Erkennung haben schwere Mängel,
sind anfällig für Angriffe, die technische Auswirkung ist die Schwächung einer
Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung und die Effektivität der ganzen Maßnahme ist in Zweifel zu ziehen.
Dann gibt es mehrere Briefe von Wirtschaftsverbänden, die also sagen,
in Anbetracht der extrem hohen Risiken ist es von entscheidender Bedeutung,
dass hier ein Gleichgewicht zwischen Kinderschutz und Privatsphäre gefunden wird.
Ohne freiwillige Maßnahmen und eine angemessene Ausnahmeregelung von den einschlägigen
Bestimmungen der Datenschutzrichtlinie werden einige Dienste nicht in der Lage
sein, proaktiv danach zu suchen.
Aufdeckungs- und Sperrungsverfügungen müssen die Maßnahmen, also das letzte Mittel sein.
Den Anwendungsbereich von solchen Aufdeckungsanordnungen sollte man auf jeden
Fall nur auf geeignete Dienstleister eingrenzen,
sich auf Dienste konzentrieren, die aufgrund ihrer Art ein hohes Missbrauchsrisiko
darstellen und die Verordnung sollte eben mit anderen EU-Rechtsvorschriften
Vorschriften abgestimmt sein.
Andere sind ein bisschen klarer, sagen, Verschlüsselte Kommunikation ist wichtig.
So eine obligatorische Aufdeckung durch Scanning sollte auf jeden Fall letzte
Ultima Ratio Mittel sein und wenden sich auch gegen die Erkennungsanordnung
auf handlungsfähige Anbieter.
Wie sieht es jetzt in Europa aus? Also wir haben festgestellt,
diejenigen, die es vollmundig angekündigt haben, Apple und das Vereinigte Königreich,
beugen sich der Realität.
Und in Europa ist es so, von der Kommission kam die ganze Sache,
spezifisch von Ilva Johansson und der EU-Kommissarin.
Der Rat, das sind die einzelnen Staaten, will seine Position im September noch
beschließen. September ist jetzt, das heißt innerhalb der nächsten drei Wochen
wird der Rat seine Position haben.
Und dann das Parlament im Oktober, da sind die gewählten Mitglieder des Europaparlamentes drin.
Und dann verhandeln die im Trilog die finale Version.
Und noch vor der Europawahl im Juni 2024 soll der ganze Kram beschlossen werden.
Das heißt aktuell diskutiert der Rat in der Ratsarbeitsgruppe Strafverfolgung.
Das geht noch ungefähr drei Wochen, weil dann ist der September vorbei.
Und Netzpolitik veröffentlicht immer die geheimen Protokolle der Sitzung.
Das ist natürlich auch schön, dass man da genau zuschauen kann.
In vielen Punkten sind sie sich schon einig. Die spanische Ratspräsidentschaft
hat auch schon einen Kompromissvorschlag vorgelegt.
Aktuell bleibt eben die Chatkontrolle, also das Client-Side-Scanning-Streitpunkt im Rat.
Interessanterweise will Deutschland das raushaben.
Österreich bezieht sich darauf, dass es nicht grundrechtskonform ist und dass
dieses Urteil unter anderem der juristische Dienst des Europäischen Rats fällt und sagen,
wir können das einschränken maximal auf bekannte Inhalte, das wäre also diese
Neck-Neck-Regelung, weil das Problem ja noch ist, dass das Ding jetzt Neues erkennen soll.
Und wenn wir sagen, wir limitieren die Beschränkung auf bekanntes Material,
gehen wir zurück zu diesem Beispiel, Bild geht von Vater an Mutter in eine WhatsApp-Gruppe oder was.
Dann ist das ja in Ordnung. Jetzt kann das gleiche Bild,
nachdem die Familie gehackt wurde und dieses Bild nun in Kreisen getauscht wird
und das dem Nack Nack dann eben bekannt wird,
Dann kann man ja sagen, das gleiche Bild ist jetzt bekannt als getauschtes Material
und eindeutig unabhängig verifiziert worden, als wird zumindest getauscht ohne
Einverständnis des Kindes und der Familie, stammt beispielsweise aus einem Heck.
Und dann kann man ja retrograd das auf jeden Fall machen und wenn man dann den
Hash quasi hat und danach sucht, sagen sie, das finden sie in Ordnung.
Aber dass irgendeine KI sagt, hör mal, da ist aber ein nacktes Kind im Bild,
da machen wir mal lieber Meldungen, lassen nochmal die Polizei drauf gucken, das eben nicht.
Die Niederlande sagen, okay, darf nur als Ultima Ratio sein,
wir wollen das auf bekanntes Material einschränken und wir wollen spezifisch
die Erkennung von unbekanntem Material ausschließen und auch die Erkennung von
Grooming ausschließen.
Das ist also die Idee, dass eine KI die Nachrichten scannt und versucht zu verstehen,
ob sich da gerade eine erwachsene Person eine Anbahnung vornimmt mit einem Kind.
Polen, das ist auch krass, Polen, nicht unbedingt dafür bekannt,
jetzt irgendwie wenig radikale Ideen zu haben, sagt, sie können eine anlasslose
Kontrolle von Nichtverdächtigten so nicht akzeptieren und beklagen sich in diesem Protokoll,
in dieser Sitzung, dass sie umfangreiche Textvorschläge gemacht haben,
die vollständig ignoriert werden.
Spanien hingegen ist voll dafür und will sogar irgendwie Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung verbieten.
Also da gibt es durchaus eine Bandbreite der Diskussion.
So, wie geht es jetzt weiter? Wenn man vier Staaten, die zusammen mindestens
35 Prozent der EU-Bevölkerung hat, dann können die eine Sperrminorität bilden.
Wenn also vier Staaten, die mindestens 35 Prozent der EU-Bevölkerung repräsentieren,
dagegen stimmen oder sich enthalten, dann können diese vier Staaten mit 35 Prozent
der EU-Bevölkerung den Vorschlag verhindern.
André schreibt, André Meister, der es veröffentlicht hat, Polen,
Niederlande, Schweden und Österreich könnten das ermöglichen,
wenn Deutschland dem Gesetz ebenfalls nicht zustimmt.
Und das sollte für Deutschland einfach sein, es verstößt nämlich sowohl gegen
den Koalitionsvertrag, als auch gegen die Position der Bundesregierung.
Wenn die Ampel also diese Dokumente ernst nimmt, muss sie im Rat gegen den Vorschlag
stimmen und damit könnte, wäre das offenbar erreicht.
Ja, das bleibt also jetzt eng, wir werden wahrscheinlich am Ende irgendeine
SPD-Person haben, die das Ding umreißt und uns das Messer in den Rücken rammt,
aber bis dahin können wir noch ein bisschen zittern.
Auch übrigens am Ende der Sendung machen wir da nochmal einen Hinweis,
dass Epicenter gerade Freelance-Entwickler sucht,
denn sie entwickeln für die Plenumsabstimmung, ich hab jetzt gesagt,
das gerade ist die Diskussion im Rat, die Plenumsabstimmung im Europaparlament
findet dann eben mit Deadline Oktober statt, ja.
Und für diese Plenumsabstimmung entwickeln sie gerade das Dear MEP Tool,
das es Menschen einfach machen soll, sich aktiv bei den von ihnen gewählten
oder sie vertretenden Abgeordneten gegen das Gesetz auszusprechen.
Am Ende machen wir immer die Jobs, aber ihr könnt euch jetzt schon vorstellen,
dass am Ende der Show Notes ein Link zu diesem Job Posting von Epicenter Works
ist für Freelance Developer.
Bin ich ja mal gespannt, was du nachher noch dazu zu erzählen hast.
Wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so viel, dann werde ich wieder Teile aus der Stellenbeschreibung
vorlesen, bis du sagst, dass ich das so detailliert nicht machen soll.
So läuft's immer.
Dann haben wir,
Eher kurze Meldungen. Es gab mal wieder ein Urteil, und zwar ist das im Spacenet-Verfahren.
Und da hat jetzt mal wieder ein Gesetz, ein Gericht geurteilt,
dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gesetzwidrig ist und man das nicht von jemandem verlangen kann.
Also das Bundesverwaltungsgericht hat gesagt, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist
illegal und bleibt illegal und das ist schön,
dass das mal wieder von einem Gericht festgestellt wurde.
Die Speicherpflicht im Telekommunikationsgesetz ist im vollen Umfang unvereinbar
mit der Datenschutzrichtlinie für elektronische Kommunikation und daher nicht
anwendbar, sagt das Bundesverwaltungsgericht gleich in zwei Verfahren.
Sorry, ich dachte es wäre nur in einem Fall gewesen. Das ist schön.
Verkehrstaten anlasslos und massenhaft zu speichern ist illegal.
Schön, dass wir damit nochmal die Gerichte bemüht haben. Störerhaftung.
Wir erinnern uns an das Phänomen der Störerhaftung. Die WLAN-Störerhaftung.
Wenn jemand dein Internet, dein WLAN benutzt Und dann Torrent macht,
zum Beispiel ohne VPN, mit, und ins IT-Crowd runterlädt als Torrent,
statt das schön bei Apple zu kaufen wie der Tim, dann bist du dran,
ja, deswegen warst du dran.
Und dann gab es nämlich eine Änderung, in der klar gesagt wurde,
ich glaube 2017 ist die in das Telemediengesetz eingeflossen,
in dem da nochmal steht, hier die Störerhaftung setzen wir spezifisch außer Kraft.
Und es ist tatsächlich, glaube ich, so, dass seitdem so WLAN ein bisschen einfacher verfügbar ist.
Und jetzt wird gerade das Digitale-Dienste-Gesetz umgesetzt,
also Digital Services Act, der muss ja jetzt von unserem Ministerpräsidenten
in das deutsche Gesetz übersetzt werden. Und bei diesem Entwurf fehlt auf einmal der Passus.
Im Paragraf 8 Telemediengesetz, wo drin steht, Störerhaftung gilt nicht,
um das nochmal zu explizieren.
Jetzt haben das aber, jetzt muss man sich auch mal überlegen,
das haben halt dann die Verbraucherschutzverbände,
die diese ganzen Dinger lesen, gemerkt und haben gesagt, Moment mal,
fehlt da die Antwort vom Bundesministerium für Digitales und Verkehr ist,
ja, keine Sorge, Das ist trotzdem dann so,
was ich ein bisschen nicht ausreichend finde und ich hoffe,
dass da jetzt sich relativ schnell klärt, dass wir das schön da wieder reinschreiben
und keine Störerhaftung jetzt aus Versehen wieder reinkommen soll.
Ja, hoffen wir mal, dass das funktioniert.
Allein schon deshalb, weil es sich ja hierbei nicht um eine Richtlinie handelt,
die wie du jetzt gerade noch meintest von uns nochmal in Gesetz.
Oh, hab ich dir nicht Act gesagt?
Ist ja Act und nicht Directive.
Genau, es ist eine Verordnung, das heißt die gilt dann wiederum unmittelbar
und direkt und muss eben nicht nochmal ein deutsches Gesetz überführt werden,
das heißt das wäre schon ganz sinnvoll, wenn diese Verordnung an der Stelle
und zweideutig ist, sonst geht halt der ganze Spaß auf europäischer Ebene dann
mit Gerichtshof und so weiter. los, um das irgendwie zu klären.
Verordnung gilt ab dem 17. Februar 2024. Damit wird ein horizontaler Rechtsrahmen.
Okay, also da das nur am Rande, wie man auch manchmal Regressionen haben kann.
Und damit wären wir bei den Terminen.
Am Samstag, den 16.09.2023,
eröffnen das Temporärhaus und das Haus der Nachhaltigkeit gemeinsam ihre neuen Räume in Neu-Ulm.
So, jetzt fragt ihr euch, was ist denn das Temporärhaus? Ja,
was ist wohl das Temporärhaus, wenn die Stadt Ulm dem Verschwörhaus den eigenen
Namen weggeklagt hat, indem es den als Marke angemeldet hat.
Was der Grund ist, dass man in Ulm eigentlich sich überhaupt nicht mehr sozial
und ehrenamtlich engagieren sollte, solange man da so behandelt wird. Ich darf das ja sagen.
Deswegen eröffnen die ihren gemeinsamen neuen Räume in Neu-Ulm und uns wird
gesagt, das ist auf der anderen Donauseite in einem ganz anderen Bundesland,
in der Augsburger Straße 23 bis 25
im ehemaligen Sportsohn Stammhaus auf doppelt so viel Fläche wie es am Weinhof in Ulm gab.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken,
ist das so? Da können wir bei Google Maps gucken zur Feier des Tages.
Ist was so.
Dass Neu-Ulm in einem anderen Bundesland ist.
Ja, Neu-Ulm liegt in einem anderen Bundesland und zwar in Bayern.
Ach du Schande.
Ja genau, da wird bestimmt alles viel besser. Also Ulm ist Baden-Württemberg.
Die Donau ist die Grenze?
Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2018,
Neu-Ulm ist Bayern, Ulm ist Baden-Württemberg und da ist in der Mitte die Grenze,
da kannst du sozusagen rüberschwimmen.
Wie fertig musst du sein, dass das soziale Engagement in deiner Stadt nach Bayern flieht.
Das ist schon eine Leistung. Definitiv.
Die sind also die sind gnadenlos bescheuert in
ulm ja und ich hoffe dass sie das hören und dass
man denen dass die dass das insbesondere ich
bin in dem fall ja involviert und lese ja so oder kriege ich ja so mit was da
noch weiter nachdem die jetzt da das die marke durchgesetzt haben gegen das
verschwörhaus damit sie die selber haben und den leuten die das ding gegründet
haben mit dem den namen gegeben haben den namen weggenommen haben
Und jetzt drohen sie denen noch hinterher, das ist niedrig.
Deswegen kann man eigentlich froh sein, wenn man so eine Donau hat und einfach
rüberschwimmt und in einem anderen Bundesland ist.
Schade, dass es dann Bayern ist.
Aber die Leute fliehen nach Bayern, wie cool musst du sein?
Okay, also genau, ich denke das ist zu feiern, weil das Verschwörhaus hat da
schwere Repressionen völlig unnötiger Art erlitten in Baden-Württemberg,
in Ulm und umso schöner, dass sie jetzt in der Augsburger Straße 23,
bis 25 am 16.09. eröffnen können, auf doppelt so viel Fläche.
Und das ist eingebettet in die Kulturnacht Ulm-Neu-Ulm.
Link in den Shownotes, wer also in Bayern oder Ulm wohnt kann nach Neu-Ulm und
an der Kulturnacht 2023 die Eröffnung des Temporärhauses.
Ich hoffe die haben schon mal drüber nachgedacht das gleich als Marke anzumelden.
Würde ich empfehlen ja.
Könnte hilfreich sein. Ach je.
Jut, jetzt kannst du deine Jobs nochmal loswerden. Jetzt bin ich ja richtig
gespannt, was jetzt kommt.
Ja, also Epicenter Works sucht einen Freelance Python Backend Entwicklerin für
die freie Kampagnen Software zur Chatkontrolle und sie hätten gerne mehrjährige Python Erfahrung,
Kenntnisse in Git und GitHub, ja, also wie man Git Add, Git Commit,
Git Branch und so weiter.
Erfahrung in der Entwicklung von RESTful APIs, optimalerweise mit Fast API.
Kenntnisse in relationalen Datenbanken und SQL Alchemy.
Sorgfältiges und lösungsorientiert, also quasi dass man versucht der Lösung entgegen zu fiebern.
Jaja so ist es gedacht.
Das kenne ich auch, wo lernt man das denn? Und hohe Eigenmotivation,
wenn du das hast, dann kannst du dich quasi bewerben auf diesen Freelance Job.
E-Mail an jobs.epicenter.org. Bitte gib im Betreff der E-Mail dmep-yourname an.
Theoretisch ist auch eine ehrenamtliche Mitarbeit möglich, aber obwohl wir dieses
Open Source Projekt rein aus Spenden finanzieren, wollen wir auch für die Arbeit bezahlen.
Da die Plenumssitzung dieses bereits Ende Oktober geplant ist,
werden Bewerbungen im Eilverfahren bearbeitet.
Sie suchen schnellstens jemanden für diese Aufgabe.
So und ihr wisst, Epicenter Works, dahinter verbirgt sich Thomas Lohninger,
der ja auch gerne Gast in unserer Sendung ist und gern gehörter Gast.
Oder Moderator oder was auch immer.
Mir wird leider nix dazu gesagt inwiefern das remote sein kann, ich geh mal davon aus.
Ich würde jetzt mal erwarten, dass die nicht sagen du musst dann in Wien tippen.
Wenn man sagt du musst Git und GitHub können, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich dafür
nicht nach Wien ziehen müssen.
Naja, was weiß ich, vielleicht haben die da so Hebel an der Wand,
wo so Komets und Mörsch und Bransch und so.
Nein, nein, hätte man bloß nochmal erwähnen können. Egal.
Ich verlinke auch noch den Vortrag von Thomas Lohninger und das Konzeptpapier. So, wunderbar.
Dann sind wir am Ende der Sendung angekommen.
Ja, ist doch schön.
Findest du nicht toll?
Doch, super.
Froh, dass es vorbei ist?
Ja, so früh am Morgen die Konzentration.
Da habe ich auch immer die großen Konzentrationsschuldigkeiten.
Wobei wir ja jetzt ausnahmsweise mal auf dem Camp mal abends eine Sendung gemacht haben.
Ja, ganz ausnahmsweise, wobei das war für mich auch schon früh am Morgen.
Ich bin es schon so gewohnt, immer guten Morgen zu sagen, dass ich da auch einfach
guten Morgen gesagt habe. Ausnahmsweise meine.
Ansonsten merke ich, ich bin so ein bisschen...
Bin so ein bisschen woke jetzt. Könnte den woke mind virus haben.
Ich fühle mich so ganz woke.
Aufgeweckt sagt man ja auch auf Deutsch.
Mir kam gerade so ein Gedanke, dass es vielleicht gar nicht so gut ist für die
Gesellschaft, wenn ein einzelner Mensch 100 Milliarden US-Dollar hat.
Ist denn Woke genau das gleiche, also ist das das, was man, wenn man im Deutschen
sagt, aufgewecktes Kerlchen?
Nein. Also der Begriff Woke wäre eher, glaube ich, in dem Kontext zu übersetzen
mit aufmerksam und wachsam.
Und der hat eben, also quasi ein wachsames Bewusstsein für soziale Ungerechtigkeit
oder Rassismus ist damit gemeint, also ja.
Das, das, so würde man das, kann man das glaube ich übersetzen, woke, wachsam.
Die Antwort war mir jetzt viel zu seriös und ernsthaft.
Ja du bist doch nicht woke genug, woke ist ne Ernstsangelegenheit.
Kann man auch gerne mal bisschen zu woke sein, wenn man irgendwie so ein woke mind virus hat.
Gehst du auf einmal gar nicht mehr petzen.
Ich muss mich jetzt erstmal ausruhen. Leute bis dann. Tschau tschau.
Well, we have a very interesting talk lined up for today. Our employee of the
month and computer expert, Jen Barber, has kindly agreed to say a few words
about her role in the IT department.
Now, speaking as someone who doesn't know the difference between a laptop and
the larger one, I'm certainly looking forward to hearing what she has to say.
Good morning. When I was asked to give a speech about what it is I do and everything, I was very excited.
At last, I thought, a chance to explain the wonders of technology to ordinary folk.
But then I thought, who wants to listen to a boring old speech?
Wäre es nicht besser, wenn ich einen von diesen Wundern mitbringen könnte, um es euch zu zeigen?
Sagen Sie, oh, ich weiß nicht, ähm... Das Internet! Ich glaube,
es würde! Und ich habe es! Meine Damen und Herren, ich möchte Ihnen das Internet vorstellen!
Oh, bitte, keine Dachfotografie, das würde das Internet beschädigen.
Meine Damen und Herren, wenn etwas zu diesem Boxen passieren würde,
The world as we know it would fall into chaos.
Planes would drop from the sky like tables. Society would tear itself apart
like an angry child with a napkin.
Man's primeval instinct to survive at any cost would lead to terrible violence.
Also bitte, keine Flaschenfotografie.